احمد الله سبحانه وتعالى انه تقريبا من 36
عام وانا اجمع كل ما له علاقه بالرؤيه
السعوديه او بشعار الدوله السفنون نقله
حقيقه من خلال بحثي استطعت انه اجمع كثير
من الاعلام في البدايات لم اكن اعرف حقيقه
تاريخ هذه هذه الاعلام ولكن
بالربط من خلال ما ذكر تاريخيا في بعض
المصادر اضافه لانه انا بعد اقتنائي
هالقطعه وغيرها من القطع يمكن زرت بعضها
فعلا قمت
بتوثيقها وسالت عن اكبر المراكز العالميه
وكان من ضمنها مركز سيران في فرنسا
لتوثيق مثل هذه القطعه ما هي مهام هذا
المركز المركز من اكبر المراكز في العالم
في عمليه
رصد وبحث وتحليل
القطع او من ضمنها القطعه القماشه بمركز
معتمد حللت مجموعه من الاعلام التي هذه
القطعه من ضمن هذه القطعه وهذا اشاروا انه
في حدود 1727 في هذه المرحله هذا العلم
يعني دعنا نقول بحدود 300 عام الا قليل
يعني تقريبا طبعا هو مش دقيق بالضبط
الى تلك المرحله الدوله السعوديه الاولى
هو صدم مشاري المركز حقيقه يعطيك ثلاث
تواريخ متقاربه يعني يعطيك بنسب معينه
يعني منسب يعني 47% في هذا التاريخ 22% في
هذا التاريخ ويعطيك البقيه في تاريخ ثالث
ولكن انت تشتغل في رينج معين انه انه
راي وتحليل المعهد العلمي الفرنسي سيرام
المعتمد في تحليل القطع الاثريه هل اكتفيت
بهذا التوفيق
تماما انه انه اصل وابحث عن كل الشخصيات
المحليه ذات اهتمام قريب من هذا الجانب
وفي مجال التاريخ
ولله الفضل منا استطعت انه احصل منهم على
التقارير من خلال فحص هذا الاعلام والوقوف
عليها لانه ليست ليس هذا العالم ولكن هناك
اعدام اعلام كثر حقيقه في مراحل مختلفه
استطعت فعلا ولله الفضل منا من اساتذه
ودكاتره ومن بيته المطرف محمد الرايه من
1906 استطعت انه احصل على تقرير كل كل شخص
تقريبا في حدود ست سبع صفحات جميل